surely if everybody gave something
nobody would have nothing
[Music]
hey I'm Dan and I'm not normal you see I
like to look at the world a little bit
differently on the daily the media tells
us that people are bad I've chosen the
route Ashok is the good darkness the
change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
imagine if 50 million people
the way I'm thinking
[Music]
I'm down the director and welcome to the
Internet it can be a pretty dark place
at times but I plan on changing that I
think that the Internet is a place which
is not safe for children there is
currently a lot of debate surrounding
the topic of the Internet and with the
help of all of you guys we can turn the
incident into a pretty colorful place
[Music]
again maybe serious I'm the filmmaker
that believes in using positivity in
order to inspire others through form and
recently I made youtuber vain Brown who
taught me the importance of as well as
challenged me to do media upload
therefore every Wednesday I'm going to
be doing a hump happiness so subscribe
to my channel and follow me on snapchat
for daily stories and I'll see you guys
in the near future
I hope you enjoyed my channel trailer
let me know what you thought in the
comments below and subscribe for next
week's episode with fun fully your lives
will change
I would really encourage you to search
for that